zahlreiche nachrichten portale berichten
über den asteroiden mit der kennung 2018
lf 16 bezeichnen ihn als monstrum mit
gigantischem ausmaß der mit rasanter
geschwindigkeit durchs all
demnach könnte er die erde schon in vier
jahren treffen und ein massensterben
auslösen was wissen wir über diesen
asteroiden um was ist wirklich dran an
dieser horrormeldungen die antworten
jetzt bei pixum science fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende wissenschafts
news abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's es soll
ein gigantischer mega street sein der
laut einigen newsseiten kurs auf die
erde nimmt und nicht nur das den
meldungen zufolge soll die nasa sogar
ein mögliches datum für seinen ein stark
auf die erde genannt haben konkret geht
es um den asteroiden mit der kennung
2018 lf 16 der mit einem durchmesser von
rund 200 metern knapp doppelt so groß
sein soll wie londons uhrturm big ben
entdeckt wurde der story dem jahr 2018
im juni wir berichten
hierbei geht es um science-fiction immer
wieder mal über also jeden von denen
manche tatsächlich eine gefahr für die
erde und das leben auf ihr darstellen
könnten denn wir sind ständig bedroht
von kollisionen mit erdnahen asteroiden
viele objekte sind klein und verglühen
in der atmosphäre ohne dass wir es
bemerken noch manche dringen eben auch
in die atmosphäre ein und das kann
fatale folgen haben
fliegende trümmer tsunami wellen und
schlimme erdbeben etwa könnten ein
großteil des lebens auf der erde
auslöschen hollywood filme zu solch
einem worst case szenario gibt es ja
genügend aber auch erdnahe asteroiden
die weniger als einen kilometer
durchmesser haben können uns gefährlich
werden denn von ihnen sind nur wirklich
ganz wenige bekannt 2013 schlug ein
solch unbekannter asteroid in der nähe
des ural gebirge sind schilder binz kein
obwohl er nur einen durchmesser von 20
metern und ein gewicht von 16.000 tonnen
hatte wurden 1500 menschen verletzt und
700 gebäude wurden beschädigt für solch
ein szenario der eben deutlich schlimmer
könnte laut einiger nachrichtenportale
eben auch der astra 2018 lf 16 auf der
erde sorgen es sind tatsächlich
meldungen die seit einiger zeit im netz
gehen und die panik verbreiten könnten
denn hier werden sogar mögliche daten
für einen einschlag auf der erde genannt
schon am achten august 2023 also in rund
vier jahren könnte es soweit sein oder
eben am dritten august 2024 und als ein
weiteres mögliches einschlags datum des
monstrums so die meldung wird dann
außerdem auch noch der erste august 2025
genannt zudem ist von 62 verschiedenen
flugbahnen die rede
die alle kurs auf die erde nehmen bzw
die sich mit der erdumlaufbahn kreuzen
könnten das alles basiert den meldungen
zufolge auf angaben der nasa schauen wir
uns das mal genauer an
fangen wir mal mit der geschwindigkeit
des asteroiden an auf der offiziellen
webseite der nasa kann man in einer
tabelle alle charakteristika von 2008 10
11 16 nachlesen
demnach ist er mit 15 kilometern pro
sekunde im all unterwegs was wir als
soliden aber durchaus normal ist das ist
also keineswegs besonders schnell
so wie es oft zu lesen ist auch was die
62 potenziellen flugbahnen mit kurs auf
unserem planeten angeht sollte man genau
hinschauen denn auch hier wird mit blick
auf die nasa tabelle deutlich was
gemeint ist jenes die us-bundesbehörde
für die nächsten 100 jahre 62 nahe
begegnung zwischen der erde und dem
asteroiden 2008 10 11 16 auf da es sich
um einen erdnahen asteroiden handelt ist
auch dass keineswegs besonders
besorgniserregend denn erdnahe hast du
ihnen ziehen und weil in der nähe der
erde ihre bahn
die eben zitierten termine im august
2000 23 24 und 25 stammen ebenfalls aus
dieser nasa tabelle
hierbei handelt es sich aber um nicht
mehr als die ersten drei daten der
insgesamt 62 vorbeiflügen von denen ich
eben gesprochen habe für jeden der
gelisteten vorbeiflüge wird auch eine
theoretische kollision
wahrscheinlichkeit genannt doch auch
hier wird wieder deutlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist wirklich nicht
extrem hoch wenn nicht sogar niedrig
denn sie liegt bei dem ersten termin im
jahr 2023 achtung bei 1 zu 370 millionen
für august 2024 sogar bei 1 zu 480
millionen und jahr 2025 liegt die
theoretische kollision zwar schein
lichkeit das us-team mit unserer erde
bei 1 zu 1,2 milliarden also wenn man
alle 62 vorbeiflüge und deren
entsprechenden einzeln wahrscheinlich
zusammenaddiert beträgt sie 1 zu 30
millionen anders gesagt damit es eine
kollision mit der erde mit einer sehr
großen wahrscheinlichkeit ausgeschlossen
natürlich muss man an dieser stelle auch
festhalten dass die bahn des asteroiden
noch nicht ganz exakt vorauszusagen ist
dennoch ist es überhaupt nicht
angebracht dass der asteroid 2008 10 11
16 irgendjemand schlaflose nächte
bereiten sollte denn laut nasa datenbank
hat er eine palermo zahl von knapp minus
6 diese palermo zahl ist ein maß um
asteroiden nach ihrer gefährlichkeit
einzustufen grob gesagt wird es ab einer
zahl kritisch die deutlich über null
liegt klar ist auch dass nasa esa und so
weiter ab einer zahl von -2 schon etwas
genauer hinsehen und dazu kommen mit
einem durchmesser von 200 metern ist er
schon groß aber keinesfalls gigantisch
oder gar ein monstrum falls er die erde
also doch treffen würde könnte dies für
die einschlags region durchaus
dramatische folgen haben doch ein
massensterben oder gar ein weltuntergang
können wir mal ausschließen denn das
steht fest 2008 10 11 16 gehört zu den
kleineren asteroiden die wir kennen also
entwarnung was aber nicht heißt dass
asteroiden ein ziemlich unkalkulierbares
risiko sind und sie können mehrere
kilometer groß sein das wäre eine
katastrophe eine solche kollision
ständig schlagen auf der erde welche 1
und beim tunguska ereignis oder beim
einschlag in chelyabinsk haben wir glück
gehabt das muss nicht so bleiben und wir
müssen ja mit einem großen einschlag
rechner oder dem unbedingt vorbeugen wie
groß die gefahr ist dass er vater in
diesem video hast du eben bedrohen die
erde jederzeit pflicht video für alle
die sich dafür interessieren also
unbedingt drauf klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran